MALE SPEAKER: We essentially
tried to reimagine classic
advertising as if it
was done today.
We're looking at the brands most
iconic [? working, ?] and
we couldn't screw that up.
Everyone could relate
to Ralph sitting on
the side of his bed.
So, what are the tools that
are available to us that
really allow us to showcase
relevancy?
We identified a list of about 20
things that we thought sort
of from a creative and
technology standpoint would be
really amazing.
A lot of the stuff that we did
in desktop can't be done in
mobile in the same way.
And so thinking about both of
those platforms at the same
time so we only solve
the problem once.
There was a constant push-pull,
and I think a
healthy one.
The ads didn't actually
run in media.
They ran for Google.
The metric, though, is whether
we could get people to engage
and do so in a way that
reimagined that
ad and did it justice.
If you look at this as a resize
of a website, if you
look at it as a resize of a
print ad, then you're not
doing with the media what it's
capable of doing, and you
won't see any of the types of
things that you really expect
to get out of it.
But if know what those things
are, if you know that this is
a channel that does things that
no other channel does,
you can create creative for
that, and see it perform
remarkably well.